[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
do we talk about web art was hitting me
he was like a pull-up I was like nah
barn I can't even do it man other week
I'm like keV cuz if we have our
favorites no yeah and then like keV and
they were all thought about this week
and then I'm like I got family my wife
was like Burt you ain't doing I'm
serious about the news ain't no just
kidding I'm serious you ain't going
nowhere
and the shoes like you might could go
outside and I was like please I won't go
see my friends this what June happen I
was like Liz please
so you're at least got longer a little
bit longer a little bit longer
I can't travel yet but she let me come
here we should have a double standard
were like she's going out doing no no no
she she was first we were like all
scared like you know the CDC this but
now the see seems like a symptomatic can
transmit and then like two days ago
they're like nevermind they can't yeah
this is like bro what you know what just
we don't know I'm asked you don't need a
mask
they're like surfaces can hold it never
and then people like hey I believe in
science stay home and then they're like
hey never mind now you can go out you're
fine it was so much going on but like
and then I found out Sweden never closed
anything the whole time and they had
like a lot but not like more they didn't
have the most you know you're doing it
based off age right like more
recommendations like if you're older
more successful you guys just stay in
your whatever homes and their regular
home yeah basically like you use your
common sense if you're old and this
might affect you more then stay home or
if you have pre-existing conditions it's
almost like people will have
self-preservation if they want to live
like the doll it's weird weird
are you concept boy do you want explain
your gloves what's going on yeah so um
this is so weird
but I found that out eczema and I'm like
so I've been getting is like these
really little blisters like a ton of
them you know that what's that one like
not a syndrome but some people they
can't look like a bunch of them cost Oh
tripped up to phobia yeah so if you have
this and you looked at it you're gonna
freak out cuz it looks like a ton of
little holes it looks nasty oh let me
see love gross stuff is the iPhone was
like that was like oh were freaking out
so I have it all over my hands and feet
and I detect it it got really itchy and
I'm like what the hell is going on so I
went to a dermatologist and I thought it
was either I felt like it was either me
swimming too much or it was this new
creatine and I was taking and then and I
was hoping it wasn't the pool and I also
swam competitively in junior high so I
was swimming like twice a day two hours
each time and I never got eczema or
anything so I'm like what the hell is
this so I went to go see the dermatology
goes it is actually the pool and he was
what he was saying is as you get older
you know how like your grandparents
their skins really thin and not really
elastics or your skin changes
mid-twenties oh yeah you're the son yeah
I get like crazy like bumps and rashes
and bad yeah so did you go to the beach
hurt like you don't care she basically
just has to pick pain and Beach or
pretty much chose to suffer to enjoy the
video it's like if I lose you to Monster
energy drinks which some people would
say you are yeah you got a kidney stone
it some would say that maybe there are
consequences I believe in science I mean
you brought it up Steve I know I was
giving you an example
I got a soft track yeah so I have this
thing called Dixie hydrosis eczema and
he's like it's it's pretty much the pool
and he was like are you coming out of
the pool and then showering right after
and I'm like no I just come out of the
pool and I pretty much an undiscussed I
call that a shower and I just we just
got this pool right so I'm swimming
every single day and every day I on an
island and coming in and out and I guess
it dried out my skin and he goes it had
you moisturized this would not happen
because you would have to run to your
wife you gave you you gave Jesus solid I
told you so doctor certified wife I told
you some told you so gloves told you so
sex oh I have like the vinyls I just got
these in from Amazon but I had like the
vinyl ones and she's laying on my lap
and we're watching like a movie oh you
guys are having sex and you hear
crinkling makes you I can't cuz before
this [ __ ] happened he had all the bug
bites so then he had like ointment on
every single part of his body and then
he had the [ __ ] nose strip and then
the mouth thing I'm like what why do you
hate sex show them the [ __ ] squishy
was happening
got two kids
this needs braces man it's just go to
the bed she's like wow this is just
lately the more you know this guy the
more nosebleeds a weird shitty day yeah
sometimes you're we're here and then
also I look over he's got a [ __ ]
tissue she's got the muscles and thought
she was getting a deal lemon got a lemon
over there oh you look so strong on
Instagram I watch you I said eating
unhealthy and I'm like man bar is doing
it my party works so hard if your ship
busts apart like every day si bar just
be like me don't try that's the problem
you try and then you fail yeah I don't
even go in pools I just like to hang
outside of them it's the vibe thing
cocktails while like nicking at the pool
we have a pool we don't go in there I
just thought we want to get wet it's a
whole thing and I got a ticket so I take
a shower right after and you're like
actually it's just like oh you got put
on everything it's just like I don't be
excited to go swimming anymore like when
I was a kid that's all we used to do
every day when I little military base
they used to have pools and that was our
summer just go ride our bikes to the
pool swim all day you have one dollar
buy chips in a sort of hell yeah and
then like not much a dollar used to be a
lot with a dollar dollar was this all
your quarters or corner you got a drink
and chips and you can even make a phone
call if you needed to man
I remember going to the gas station and
coming back like a Trick or Treat basket
of like candy with a dollar do my
community pool you could get certified
to swim there when you're like 10 9
years old so I could go down there with
on bikes with my friends and we did all
that [ __ ] there man I can feel the
Funyuns in my hands yeah yeah he's great
ice cream and calm you skin tight I
spent all my money on chips the first
time I laid the ice cream man came and
he was selling corn
didi also had the fruit with it yes I
love it
did he have the big cube of ice it's
that's frickin Mexican culture I want to
appropriate it when I came my son school
they had the corn guy he had fun on both
sides like once you picked him up either
way you went you had to go on escape so
we just took 20 bucks at beginning a
week and just set it aside corn I seize
corn allowance oh man
Manny's cheese yeah oh it's so good and
sometimes they have Funyuns there and
actually outrages me because those are
my peoples food I used to always go to
the pool - and then that's why when I
developed the Sun allergy in my mid-20s
I'm like what the [ __ ] it actually
happened during their wedding in Hawaii
really started getting my rashes and I'm
like I thought I was allergic to the
salt water or this you're allergic to
love how long does it take for you
activated if it's like an hour but is
yeah like that you have to prepare a
skin that doesn't know it's a pretty tan
but I never do what is it this pretend
they're like expose my skin slowly to
the Sun like like 20 minutes a day and I
should be doing that like if I have a
vacation planned up whatever they're
supposed to do
I'm supposed to wear a [ __ ] ton of
sunscreen and like I would never wear
Sun what if you buy one of those lamps
for like a lizard oh it's a clamp oh the
red ones yeah and you just clamp it
right there so you just watch TV that's
a bar thing to do you would actually do
that if I'm even a pre tamil that I'm
gonna fight the Sun and I'm gonna get
ready for it this is more of like a [ __ ]
you to my dermatologist because this way
your gloves yeah you like your gloves I
do like my bottom okay he's not
explaining it I don't even need these
[ __ ] though later calves in the blood
can I see your [ __ ] I'm a peel it off
isn't lightweight that's it then I'm
like wow I don't really even need gloves
he's already competing with bar Jordan
that's tobacco Jordan like everything
has to have to have a vengeance against
someone okay so you said [ __ ] you to
your dermatologist who's trying to help
you and treat it well the way he talked
to me he was like all right sir put this
on four times a day not three not that's
a good moisturizer
oh is it yeah and I was like yeah I'll
put it on four times a day because so
many people come in here and then they
don't heal and then I go how many times
I should put it on and he go
oh really only just two and I'm like no
I'm gonna put on four goes really you
know probably if you not look at you
obviously you're a man of dedication
like consistency and also I think like I
don't even know if you misdiagnosed me
because I kept trying to stick my hand
in his face and just like so he could
really take a look and he was already
just walking around I know what it is
and I'm like you want to take a closer
look like not I know what it is I'm
gonna write the prescription so I know
now I'm gonna be like I'm a [ __ ] heel
in your [ __ ] face and show you that
I've been putting it on for you know how
hard you just wrecked this guy you just
gave him a free ad and told everyone
that he cured you
you'll be like and I hear bro
see miss nothing because I did what you
said
so who's the doctor now you okay bart's
yelp review is one star and the most
glowing review this guy actually told me
that the exact what he said and it
worked out fine but the way he talked to
me
I appreciate El he didn't think it was
basically you showed him an apple and he
studies an apple like a million times I
gots an apple you know what do you want
to look closer he's like good choice on
my feet too and he was like nah why
don't you look at it I heard that you
have a message breath I do have a
message because this OP directors
brought to you by feels do you
experience stress or have anxiety or
chronic pain or do you have trouble
sleeping at least once a week I know I
do
you're not alone and many of us do so
what is feels feels is a premium CBD
delivered directly to your doorstep and
it naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
pain and sleeplessness I know a lot of
people like our buddy David he has a
hard time sleeping so people they just
need to relax that's when me the
thoughts going on the mind so see buddy
helps place a few drops of feels under
your tongue and feel the difference
within minutes and Athena remember about
CBD is that finding a right dose is
important because everyone's dose is
different so leave leave room to
experiment over the course of a week or
so and you may need to take more or less
to get the effects that you're after and
what's really cool about this is that
they have real human support because if
you're new to CBD new causes some scary
stuff what does it have to be feels
offers a free CBD hotline to help you
guide your personal experience and it
works naturally to help you feel better
there's no high no hangover or addiction
join the fields community it feels
delivered to your door every single
month you'll save money on every order
and you can pies or cancel at any time
exactly so become a member today by
going to feels calm slash off the record
and you'll get 50 percent off your first
order with free shipping that
f.e ALS calm / off-the-record to become
a member and get 50% automatically taken
off your first order with free shipping
once again feels calm / off the record
so if you got that one doctor that's
like I don't think you can sleep
take this shim but I slept [ __ ]
yeah I mean Bart's been really sexy
these days so yeah I'm uh not jealous
about anyone else here but that's what I
want these gloves cuz I can heal fast
and then I'll get a new [ __ ] no no I
don't wanna I don't want to have like
chronic eczema Lee I don't want to like
always have to put [ __ ] on that's I'm
really trying to like over Louie was
like take a shower and moisturize you
dumb [ __ ] and you're okay you're not
getting the pool now I haven't gotten
the pool in like a week does it give you
a tinge of satisfaction to see him with
the gloves on for her [ __ ] it it's like
I've been telling you all this [ __ ]
always like you had any blood his own
eardrum like there's a new injury I told
you how did you blow out your ear okay
so the eardrum being so I've been
swimming like non-stop since our pool
got finished right and then so like like
the water makes your ear ear wax go
around whatever and then so this ear I
couldn't hear out my right ear anymore
as he used so he has dry what yeah try
it your way
yeah mmm and I have wet earwax you nose
will see use q-tips but I grew up in the
generation and you use q-tips to clean
your ears I still clean my ears he goes
opposed to you know you shouldn't put
anything more they could get to you it's
like pushing it in more yeah um so he
already doesn't need it he has like I've
only seen it in Asian markets but they
have like this like hook type of thing
that you put in there and you'll just
scoop it out cuz it's dry yeah um but he
likes to use mine so all he's really
doing is pushing it in there and [ __ ]
compact it uh which leads to this virus
so I couldn't have yes
so I've dealt with this before crisis
swim so I got this little spray kit
where you spray it's like a squeeze
squeeze bottle and this shoots like a
stream of water in
dislodges the a good day for your ear
exactly yeah yeah so you squeeze it like
this it goes in in the and it all falls
out and you can use your ear yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you get a ton of like you
get a ton of nasty ones let's see the
[ __ ] yeah I want to see yeah so I do
think it like red is it a black black
knowing you is so disgusting I think
everyone should hug psycho when you see
him he's a miracle that he's around yeah
seriously like the one time I was able
to like pull it all together and have
sex with Bart I'm surprised he can come
regularly I don't have to get some kind
of [ __ ] tool again to come like
really not the crust that's in there
most people have wet comport has dry
Cohn it's black well anyways so I clear
this one out and after I clear this one
out I'm like oh [ __ ] like I can hear
everything and I'm like wait I think
this one's this one's clogged so it took
like three squeezes or three rounds of
squeezes to clear this one out so I
started going here and after three
rounds it still was clogged so I might
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this fool doesn't
want to listen go back to that I start
squeezing it as [ __ ] hard as I can to
get the strongest stream my eardrums
hurt all of a sudden I hear this pop
idea vertigo and I feel all this liquid
drip down the back of my throat and into
the back of my neck and it hurts like
[ __ ] I'm like what the [ __ ]
and then I text a couple of my Navy SEAL
friends because I'm like these fools
probably pop their eardrums before
because they look they go scuba all the
time and then they told the symptoms and
they're like yep I think you popped your
eardrum because you have vertigo and you
can't have balance but the pain does go
away literally in a second it hurts like
crazy and it goes away in a second and
they're like you just have to let it
heal on its own by itself and then after
two weeks if there's a problem Oh still
then you need surgery it's not supposed
to be swimming but then this forward
[ __ ] go in the pool
I'm still swimming so I just jump in the
pool like this and I miss something the
wax thingy and then he's in the pool and
he's taking a picture himself and send
it to his Navy SEAL friends
you [ __ ] I'm swimming [ __ ] do
you're gonna die you're the one that
gets hurt like I'll show you body my own
body say [ __ ] you feet and then he's
like your black footed [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm gonna run on you extra
hard he broke his [ __ ] toe and he's
like oh you want to be a [ __ ] toe you
want to be a [ __ ] and he did like more
[ __ ] stuff oh that was the old bar I
don't even know your dumb heels on its
own apparently after like two weeks
because it's just like a flap and then
it just slowly just heals but if I think
you have like fluids coming out or if it
still really hurts then you need surgery
it's weird the did you taste the liquid
better so much I wasn't really tasty you
just felt like a bunch of like you know
when you're like swimming and then all
of a sudden sometimes water goes up your
nose yeah it feels weird it's like that
but all the way back your throat cuz
your ears nose and throat are connected
right they have the ear nose and throat
doctors right yeah my son had he had
really small ear ear drums when he's a
kid and he had he had a have eustachian
tubes put in his ear cuz he said get
here so used to get crazy ear infections
over and over and over like crying
chronic ear infection that's so they had
to put a little like I like stopper yeah
basically like spacers Stoppers in his
ear to like open it up a little bit so
that his ear was drain right so you
gotta have surgery and they just fell
out one time and it was funny like it's
not funny but it is funny well he was a
baby we go ahead they took him to get a
hearing test and when you're small they
can't say hey did you hear it in your
right or your left here so they penny
sounds and then you like look to where
you heard it so like sound over here
he'd look you know he was super small in
the sound over here he'd look may has
little monkey playing the drums in front
of him and they played that sound
he freaked out and it was the funniest
thing ever supposed to be funny but like
that was the end of the test they're
like nevermind we just can't do it we've
never seen a monkey play the drums just
like yeah it was all called
chuck-e-cheese Oh another funny part of
parenthood seeing little kids see a nine
foot tall mouse to them is hilarious
maybe I you think Chuck is gonna make
them happy and they just freak out like
you comes around the corner like and how
big that thing probably feels to them
it's not cool how has that worked as a
business I have no idea it low-key one
of my guilty pleasures chugging cheese
pizzas traction Street facts right there
yeah there was the time mile a clown's
going there every week for somebody's
birthday party and I was like I mean the
pizza is Bob it's a solid worse I used
to crave that smell
what yeah because like we didn't get to
go to Chuck E Cheese cuz it was in the
next city over like because Santa
Barbara's really really small but you
could go to Ventura which is 30 minutes
away
so basically I only went like twice in
my life and like I the first time I went
it was like the most magical place ever
and then the second time I like
remembered that smell and I was like I
wish I could come here all the time it's
a very specific smell yeah nationwide it
smells like that consistently it's like
Apple comeon food yeah yeah that's the
brand before anyone Kentucky trademark
smell three years ago I walked into one
just to smell it and I acted like I was
looking for somebody but I wasn't I just
wanted this normal you Chuckie Cheese
yeah you can't go in there an adult you
never told me that
yeah that's weird repo go on your way
somewhere else yeah bye okay you didn't
just say home and it's that's true that
is very weird you do look like a dad
that lost his kid thank you
or stolen when you were like 19
[Music]
[Music]